Let's try to get our heads
around the idea of divergence.
So first, like I did with
gradients, I'll show you the
mechanics, which are actually
pretty straightforward.
And then I'll try to
give you the intuition.
And once you have the
intuition, at first it
will seemed very, I don't
know, unintuitive, maybe.
But it once you get it,
you're like oh, that's it.
So let's see what
divergence is.
Let's say I have
a vector field.
And let's say this vector
field, just for the purposes
of visualization it could be
anything, but let's say it
represents the velocity of
particles of fluid of any
point in two dimensions.
So it's going to be a
two-dimensional vector field.
It's going to be a function of
x and y, so the velocity at any
point-- it's a vector field --
let's say it is, and I'm just
going to make up something.
Let's say it's x squared, yi.
So at any point in the
x-direction, at any point x
comma y, its velocity in the
x-direction will
be x squared, y.
And then its velocity in the
y-direction, I don't know
maybe it's just 3y, j.
That's its velocity
in the x-direction.
So its velocity in the
x-direction is actually
a function of x and y.
its velocity in the y-direction
is just a function of y.
So what is the divergence?
So a couple of ways
we can write it.
The correct way to write
it is the divergence of
our vector field, v.
But a common mnemonic to
remember the operation of
diverge and is to write the
upside down triangle, which was
the same notation we used for
gradient, but take the dot
product of that and the vector.
And if you remember from the
gradient discussion, we said
that you can view, although
it's kind of an abuse of
notation, but you could view
this upside down triangle as
being equal to the partial
derivative with respect to x in
the x-direction plus the
partial derivative with respect
to y in the y-direction,
which is the j-unit vector.
And then if we went to three
dimensions, the partial
derivative with respect to
z and the k-direction,
et cetera, et cetera.
But we're dealing with a
two-dimensional vector here,
so let's just stick with
two dimensions, x and y.
So what would this
turn out to be?
If you took the dot product of
this, which is this upside down
triangle, with this vector
field, what would you get?
Well, you would just get the
partial derivative of the x
dimension with respect to x, so
you would get-- it's actually
pretty straight forward to
memorize; you might not even
need this mnemonic right here,
this abuse of notation; you
might just know it off hand
--the x component, you take the
partial derivative with respect
to x, and the y component, you
take the partial derivative
with respect to y.
But I'll show you why it
looks like the dot product.
So if you took the dot product
of that and that, it would be
the partial derivative with
respect to x of that
expression, of x squared, y and
then plus the partial
derivative with respect to y of
that second expression, the y
component of 3y, and then
you would evaluate it.
What's the partial derivative
of this with respect to x?
We just pretended y is a
constant, just a number, so
the derivative of this with
respect to x, would be
2x times the constant.
So it'll be 2xy plus-- what's
the partial derivative
of 3y with respect to y?
Well, there's nothing else to
hold constant, so it's just
like taking the derivative
with respect to y
--so it's 2y plus 3.
So this is the divergence
at a point x, y.
You could almost view it
as a function of x and y.
So you could almost say you
know, that the divergence of
v-- I'm going to make up some
notation here --as long as you
get the point across, you can
say that the divergence
of v, that this is a
function of x and y.
That we just have an expression
that if you give me a point
anywhere in this vector
field, I can tell you the
divergence at that point.
So I think you'll find that
the computation of divergence
isn't too difficult.
You just take the partial
derivative of the x component
with respect to x, and you add
that to the partial derivative
to the y component
with respect to y.
And if you had the z, you
would do the same thing,
so on and so forth.
Actually, let me do just do one
more just hit the point home,
and then we'll work
on intuition.
So if I said that I had, I
don't know, let's say, my
vector field is cosine of yi
plus-- so it's interesting; my
x-direction is dependent on
my y-coordinate --plus, I
don't know, e to the xyj.
So then oh, that's difficult
because I have these
e's and these cosines.
But we'll see; if you just
keep your head straight on
what's constant and what's
not, it's not too bad.
So the divergence of v is equal
to the partial derivative
of this expression
with respect to x.
Well, what's the derivative
of this with respect to x?
If y is just a constant,
cosine of y is just a number.
So the derivative of this with
respect to x is just 0 plus--
what's the derivative of
this with respect to y?
Well, you could just do x,
since it's a constant,
as the coefficient on y.
So the derivative of x, y
with respect to y is just x.
And then the derivative of e
to anything is e to anything.
I just did the chain rule.
e to the x, y.
And so that is the divergence.
So you could just ignore this.
It's x, e to the x, y.
One thing to immediately
realize, even before we work on
the intuition, is when we did
gradient I gave you a surface
and it gave us a vector field.
Or I gave you a scalar field
and you got a vector field.
When you take the divergence of
something, you're going in the
opposite direction,
in some ways.
You start with the
vector field, right?
And what's a factor field?
It's something that if you
give me any point x and y,
I'll give you a vector.
So if you wanted to graph it,
in the x, y plane you'd have a
bunch of vectors, and I'll show
you how that looks in a second
when we go over to intuition.
Well, when you take the
divergence of it, you get a
value for any point x, y.
So even though a vector field
has all these vectors on it,
the divergence tells you an
actual scalar number at
any point in the field.
So let's get a little bit
of intuition of what a
divergence actually is.
Let me do it in one dimension.
Or we can even, let's do it
in two dimensions, but I'll
make it constant in the y.
So let's say that my-- let me
erase this; I'll probably
need some space.
OK, oh, I didn't want
to do that dot.
OK let's say the velocity of
fluid, or the particles in
fluid, at any point in the x, y
plane, let's say it is equal to
5xi plus, I don't know, 0y--
there's never any, sorry --0j,
right? j is the unit vector
in the y-direction.
So there's never a y component
to the velocity vector.
So what would that look like?
I don't need a computer
to draw this.
I can handle this
one myself I think.
So if that's the y-axis,
that's my x-axis.
So when x is equal-- I'll just
sample some points and draw
some vectors --when x is equal
to 1-- let's say x is 1 there
--what's the magnitude
of this vector?
It'll be 5, right?
Actually, let me make this a
different number, because
it'll make it hard to do.
Let's make this 1/2 x.
So when x is 1, the magnitude
of my vector is 1/2.
Only in the x-direction.
It has no y component;
ignore this right here.
It's 1/2xi plus 0j.
Or you could just say 1/2xi.
And when x is equal to 2-- I
could have picked any points,
but I'm just picking the
numbers that's easy to
calculate --when x is equal to
2, what is the magnitude
of the vector?
It's 1/2 times 2, which is 1.
So it's going to
be twice as big.
And remember, if I have a
particle right here in my
fluid, if this is a particle,
its velocity in the x-direction
is going to be 1 meter
per second to the right.
If I have a particle here, it's
velocity in the x-direction
is going to be 1/2 a meter
per second to the right.
Let's just do one more point.
So let's say that
x is equal to 3.
What's my velocity
to the right?
I'll do it in a different
color just so that you
don't get confused.
There's going to be 3/2; it's
going to be even longer.
But the general idea here,
and as we move up in x it
doesn't change much, right?
It doesn't change at all.
Our x value doesn't--
[COUGHS].
So for any y, the magnitude
of the vector doesn't
change, right?
It's only dependent on x.
And then for example, here,
it'll be even longer.
If we draw the vector here
it'll be even longer, right?
If you do it here.
I think you get the point.
The further you go to the
right, the faster the particles
are moving towards the right.
So now let's try to get a
little bit of intuition.
Oh, I just realized that I ran
out of time, so I will continue
this in the next video.